this is young holds an alpine village
like you see in postcards it's actually
in Austria but only accessible from
across the German border it doesn't have
a bakery or even a supermarket but it
does have three banks three banks for
only 300 residents white the logon
thought that those three banks have
deposits of about 4 billion euros it's a
lot of money ninety-nine percent if it
comes from Germany and most of it is
likely undeclared clever yep there were
never any border controls in this pretty
little place so Germans could open
secret bank accounts here by just
driving down the road Austria has now
agreed to reveal details of the accounts
to German tax authorities it's only a
question of time neither the bank's nor
the mayor would comment okay pipe on the
banks are by far the biggest source of
tax revenue in your hopes and also the
largest employer but maybe not for much
longer if the tax haven has closed down
the three banks could go out of business
as yet stun compass I will have to see
what happens next but yet the banking
secrecy rules are going to change and
we'll just have to see what the future
brings responsive arashi lasse it could
be a nasty surprise yo Holtz boasts
hiking trails in the summer and skiing
in the winter just like other places
nearby but because of the money pouring
into the banks the village long ago lost
interest in tourism the two big hotels
are closed but across the border in
Germany the village of verta has more
cows and fewer foreign bank accounts
with a few vacation cottages but no
hotels the community lives from a
relatively normal mix of farming tourism
and commerce the mayor says they used to
be envious of young holds you hadn't
immediately thought of you we never had
the fun
that were available to the people of yum
Holt's you can still notice it today we
get revenue from business tax income tax
and a few other taxes and it's a lot
less than what you mulch is getting so
these dumbots in your midst of all so
very tough is as relaxed as ever about
what the future will bring unlike their
neighbors in young Holt's who are
concerned that their livelihood is about
to dry up